some mixed fractions
look at the number four one by three
yes it's just one number we have seen
numbers like four
it's a whole number one by 3 is a proper
fraction
a proper fraction is a fraction in which
the numerator
is less than the denominator this mixed
fraction
is simple to understand it's the sum of
these two parts
the whole part and the fractional part
let's write the whole part a bit
differently
4 can also be written as 12 by 3 because
3 times 4 is 12 and we write 1 by 3 as
is when two fractions having the same
denominator are added
we can simply add the numerators over
the common denominator
let's zoom out slightly this can be
written as
twelve plus one by three add the
numerators over the denominator
and it becomes thirteen by three so this
mixed fraction can also be written as an
improper fraction four 1 by 3
is the same as 13 by 3 but let's look at
a very logical way of understanding
mixed fractions
we're looking at the mixed fraction for
1 by 3.
we represent this 4 with 4 circles of
the same size
what about the fractional part 1 by 3
the fractional part is 1 divided into 3
equal parts
so for 1 by 3 we draw one circle
and divide it into three equal parts
it's one part out of these three parts
now let's shade one part to represent
one by three
now we have four plus one by three
these four circles can be looked at in a
different way
we divide each of these circles into
three equal parts
nothing changed we just divided each
circle into three
equal parts to represent four
we shade the four circles what did we
just do
we shaded twelve one by three parts
one two three four five six
seven eight nine and ten eleven twelve
this should make it clear the red shaded
parts can be written as twelve by three
twelve one by three parts and this blue
shaded part can be written as
one by three adding all these parts
should give us
four one by three adding this
gives us thirteen by three keep in mind
the fractional part in a mixed fraction
should always be a proper fraction
which means its numerator should be less
than its denominator